I don't know how many of you have been
following the anti-semitic sort of troll
group
that has been harassing Jewish folks uh
in Florida and in other parts of the
country but I have absolutely
fascinating video of Volusia Sheriff
Mike Chitwood
going nuclear on these Neo-Nazi lunatics
this is a very interesting video I'm
going to play for you this was from just
a few days ago The Daily Beast article
about it explains a week after a
Neo-Nazi hate group circulated through
the Daytona Beach Florida area
displaying and distributing extremist
propaganda the County's Top Cop has had
enough a seething Volusia Sheriff Mike
Chitwood held the press conference on
Monday said this isn't about Free Speech
this is about violence it is very very
much worth looking at this take a listen
You'll first hear just a few seconds
this is video from Vice news a few
seconds of these so-called protesters
just harassing Jewish people and then
we'll hear from uh Sheriff Chitwood
Kyle hey you filthy Jewish
we are not going to tolerate this let me
tell you this is not about Free Speech
this is about violence two days after
the incident at the speedway one of
these gdl members remember gdl means
goyum Defense League it's it's an
anti-semitic group
bushed and shot two Jewish Orthodox
folks outside of their synagogue in L.A
there's a lot of people in this room and
there's a lot of people around this
country of the Jewish faith who are on
their hit list
they try to be smirk your character
they try to put death threats out on you
and threaten you and your family yeah
well I wear that as a badge of honor
because I too by these clown group want
to shut my big mouth and put a bullet in
the back of my head go for it that's my
message to you go for it you came to the
wrong County I stand with my Jewish
friends and I'm honored to be on your
Hit List it's an honor to be to be short
after by a bunch of punk thugs like you
that's my personal message with that
I'll turn it over to people who are
commonly
the calmer people will now be allowed to
speak listen good good for this guy and
this of course alone isn't actually
going to shut these clowns down but the
part of the problem is
it gets some attention the these clowns
get some attention and the videos sort
of go viral but then it doesn't get the
same serious handling that some other
things do and as the sheriff points out
it's very easy to say all right they're
standing outside of a dairy mart with a
sign about Jews but it goes beyond that
and it gets to it becomes real world
violence and we see examples of it so
good for the sheriff more folks should
be aware of the fact that these troll
groups are harassing people who are or
who they believe to be Jewish and
sometimes they're just wrong sometimes
they harass people who aren't even
Jewish now that it matters but it just
sort of like by the way
um and uh if more sheriffs and if law
enforcement dealt with it more the way
Sheriff Chitwood is uh we would probably
all be far better off so good for him we
have a YouTube channel youtube.com the
davidpackman show which I would love for
you to subscribe to it's free to do and
we also have a Spanish YouTube channel
which you can find at davidpackman.com
Spanish whichever of the two languages
you prefer to consume uh Progressive
political analysis in it is available to
you and that's a beautiful thing